so I know that Donald Trump is
pretending like Ron DeSantis has no
chance to beat him in a primary and I
think it's quite possible that Ron
DeSantis can't beat Trump in a primary
but I don't believe for a second that
Trump's not worried Trump is posting
almost daily about Ron DeSantis on Truth
social which we will get to a little bit
later but Trump actually seems so
panicked about DeSantis that he is lying
uncontrollably about him all the time
simple easily to disprove lies here is a
clip from Trump yesterday on Sebastian
gorka's show if you're not up to speed
on this program I forgive you it's not
exactly uh the this show is not exactly
on the Vanguard of political analysis
but in any case in just a few seconds
Trump tells multiple lies about DeSantis
while ignoring the fact that the things
which he is accusing Ron DeSantis of he
actually did himself I won't even tell
you what they are let's see if if you
can pick them up here well thank you
very much it's nice and we do have we
have such incredible spirit and love out
there you see that in these polls you
know you have people they started
everybody thinks they're wonderful I
mean look Ron who I know well he tried
to cut Social Security he wanted to
bring the minimum age to 70 or above he
wanted to cut Medicare you know that's
not when people hear that they're not
going to be voting for him okay there
are so many lies in there already so so
there's two parts to this first of all
Trump proposed cutting Medicare and
Social Security every year he was in
office either through the budgets that
he submitted which you can say well
that's a political document it wasn't
the budget that was okay but it's the
budget Trump submitted Trump's budget
proposal would have cut Medicare and
Social Security
and Trump also said if we win the
payroll tax will be rescinded that's how
you fund Social Security and Medicare
there is no way to get rid of the
funding source for all of Social
Security and Medicare
and not to cut Social Security and
Medicare can't do it it's impossible so
Trump proposed multiple different ways
that would lead to cuts to Social
Security and Medicare but Trump says
well DeSantis proposed cutting it I'm
not a defender of Ron DeSantis but it's
not really true that Ron DeSantis did
that what DeSantis did do three times
okay 2013 2014 and 2015. DeSantis voted
in favor
of Republican study committee budget
resolutions which if they passed were
non-binding and wouldn't actually have
been cuts to Social Security and
Medicare now you can say well his
intention was to
fine
it's an exaggeration given Trump's
background with cutting Social Security
and Medicare let's watch a little more
of this delusional clip and he's
certainly not going to win in a general
election but he's you're not going to
win the Republican primary in my opinion
either he wants to cut Social Security
that's not that's not good and numerous
times you know he's a disciple of Paul
Ryan
and Paul Ryan is the worst he's the
worst he destroyed Romney Mitt Romney
could have won that race but Paul Ryan
was a disaster as a pick that was the
wheelchair over the cliff if you
remember the famous wheelchair over the
cliff which is what they oh they stung
them with and it was very hard for them
to get away from it they didn't get away
from it right so you know there's a lot
there's a tremendous amount of love out
there it's uh it's pretty incredible
it's all love as you can imagine
um one more clip from this interview
here is uh someone proposing that
instead of wrong Ron de sanctimonious
Trump instead referred to DeSantis as
Ron distablishment which is man what
what a primary we're up against here
well we'll talk about the next election
and uh your comments on the ballot
harvesting but yeah you made we need to
get to those incisive comments about
ballot harvesting now three years out
now the news on Truth social and uh on
your recently with your new nickname for
the governor of Florida Ronda
sanctimonious uh Mr G does somebody else
has come up with a a another nickname
what what is the nickname you have for
us Jeff it's got to be Ron's
establishment Mr President Ron The
Establishment what do you think of that
that's not bad I've heard worse you know
they came out with lots of different
names meatball I didn't like that one
too much but uh they came out with a lot
of different names and that's not bad
I've heard of worse yeah all right so
Trump is workshopping uh other nicknames
for wrong Des Sanctus
um there he is just telling lies and
he'll continue to tell those lies for as
long as he's allowed to do it at some
point maybe Ron DeSantis will take it
head on and say it's not true your
budgets actually sought to cut Social
Security and Medicare for the time being
DeSantis isn't running so he's not
taking it on from a policy perspective
it's a new year many of us are trying to
make new positive changes here's
something really simple that could be a
game changer our sponsor athletic greens
every day I take a scoop of ag1 I get 75
high quality vitamins minerals and Whole
Food sourced ingredients to last me all
day long this way I just know my
nutritional bases are covered for the
entire day it has everything I want and
that's important to me rather than doing
the individual supplements and vitamins
or whatever
I don't want to do any of that okay ag1
is the simplest way to just get
everything I want for my nutritional
Foundation each day ag1 is also a great
bang for your buck you're going to end
up spending way more on all those
bottles of vitamins and supplements and
minerals so save some money make your
life easier just a scoop of ag1 I love
the travel packs which let me take ag1
wherever I go I have the big pack of
ag-1 at home and when you go to
athleticgreens.com Pacman you'll get
five free travel packs plus a free year
supply of vitamin D which I use during
the winter the link is down below